alors je dois peut-être rendre à césar
ce qui est à césar on va en fait j'ai
retiré le texte
de ce formidable site qui s'appelle les
classiques
des sciences sociales si vous connaissez
pas vous lâcher un peu la pub pour ce
site
qui est un site canadien
je vous le mets dans le chat
est donc ici on peut avoir accès
vraiment à des auteurs classiques aussi
des auteurs plus contemporains mais bon
disons ce qui m'intéresse c'est surtout
les auteurs classiques et donc pas par
exemple si on va sur proudhon on va
pouvoir aller chercher plusieurs textes
de proudhon alors je dis tout de suite
que le problème c'est que parfois il ya
des coquilles dans le texte mais bon
après on va pas se plaindre non plus
c'est gratos c'est assez complet il n'ya
pas d'auteur n'est pas d'auteur je n'ai
pas trouvé là enfin quand on parle
vraiment des classiques et donc ici par
exemple qu'est ce que la propriété on a
même plusieurs formats qui sont proposés
donc que demander de plus franchement
merci merci pour ce travail de
compilation
allez-y c'est vraiment intéressant
voilà qu'est ce que la propriété comme
je voulais dit c'est le premier mémoire
d'une série de 3840 et on va directement
allé voir peut-être tout ce qui est le
plus intéressant c'est le passage dans
lequel il affirme je suis anarchiste
quelle forme de gouvernement allons-nous
préférait et pouvez vous le demandez
répond sans doute quelques uns de mes
plus jeunes lecteurs vous êtes
république un républicain oui mais ce
mot ne préciserait 1 res publica c'est
la chose publique or quiconque veut la
chose publique sous quelque forme de
gouvernement que ce soit peut se dire
républicain eh bien vous êtes démocrate
non au quoi vous seriez monarchique non
constitutionnels dieu m'en garde vous
êtes donc aristocrate point du tout vous
voulez un gouvernement mixte encore
moins qui est vous qui êtes vous donc je
suis anarchiste je vous entends vous
faites de la satire parce qu'à l'époque
le terme anarchiste est négatif
ceci est à l'adresse du gouvernement en
aucune façon vous venez d'entendre ma
profession de foi sérieuse et mûrement
réfléchie quoique très amis de l'ordre
je suis donc quoique très amis de
l'ordre c'est pour ça que quand on dit
l'anarchie c'est le désordre c'est une
bêtise et ce texte est vraiment
fondateur parce qu'en 1840 le terme
anarchiste est toujours négatif est ici
proudhon pour leur première fois
l'utilisent de manière positive et donc
quoique très amis de l'ordre je suis
dans toute la force du terme anarchiste
écoutez moi
je pars lire tout le passager à d'autres
endroits où ils utilisent toujours ce
terme anarchie alors je propose quand
même que ça on les passe en vue ainsi
dans une société donnée l'autorité de
l'homme sur l'homme est en raison
inverse du développement intellectuel
auquel s'étaient pas revenue
l'anarchie pour proudhon pour les
penseurs anarchiste je veux dire moderne
mais quand je dis moderne c'est à partir
de proudhon
c'est pas du tout l'anarchie c'est pas
la lassitude la société primitive comme
on pourrait le penser un c'est plutôt un
état de développement
extrême et la maturité absolue de de la
société
et la durée probable de cette autorité
peut être calculée sur le désir plus ou
moins général d'un gouvernement bref
c'est à dire un gouvernement selon la
science est donc ça c'est aussi
intéressant chez proudhon c'est une idée
qu'on retrouvera chez max c'est d'avoir
une approche scientifique pour le
gouvernement le marxisme au départ le
capital c'est une analyse qui se veut
scientifique du rapport
du rapport social qu'est le capital et
de même que le droit de la force et le
droit de la rue se restreignent devant
la détermination de plus en plus large
de la justice et doivent finir par
s'éteindre dans l'égalité de même la
souveraineté de la volonté c'est devant
la souveraineté de la raison et finira
par s'anéantir dans un socialisme
scientifique que l'on retrouve cette
idée la propriété et la royauté sont en
démolition dès le commencement du monde
comme l'homme cherche la justice dans
l'égalité la société cherche l'ordre
dont la marche i way c'est quand même
assez assez puissant et assez
rock'n'roll la société cherche l'ordre
dans l'anarchie anomie ouais sauf que
moi le terme d'anomie je ne l'utiliserai
même pas pour ça quoi
quand des élèves utilisent le terme
anarchy pour dire ouais c'est l'anarchie
c'est du n'importe quoi j'ai dit non ça
c'est le chaos j'utilise le terme le
chaos parce que pour l'anomie c'est
plutôt une situation enfin moi je suis
une base sûre sur ce qu'on dit durkheim
l'anomie c'est vraiment la situation où
les normes et la société sont vraiment
plus adaptée quoi les normes son
décalage par rapport au fonctionnement
même de la société je pense
qu'actuellement dans une société qui est
à fond anomique pour moi un peu
anarchique à aux anneaux mis ces trois
choses différentes en fait anarchie
absence de mettre deux souverains telle
est la forme de gouvernement dont nous
approchons tous les jours et donc là on
retrouve l'idée ce que je disais tout à
l'heure à fait x que l'anarchie c'est
pas une question de faire une révolution
en afrique c'est toujours aller plus
loin dans les rapports au quotidien de
créer des structures anarchique de enfin
je sais pas c'est une structure peut
être marre chic mais de créer des
modalités d'organisation
anarchique qui finalement vont vider de
tout son sens l'état moderne
et qui vont dépouiller le gouvernement
de tout son pouvoir quelque part donc
dont nous approchons que les jours et
que l'habitude invétéré de prendre
l'homme pour règle et sa volonté pour
loi nous fait regarder comme le comble
du désordre et l'expression du chaos on
raconte qu'un bourgeois de paris du
xviie siècle ayant entendu dire qu'à
venise il n'y avait pas de roi ce
bonhomme ne pouvait revenir de son
étonnement et pense à mourir de rire à
la première nouvelle d'une chose si
ridicule
telle est notre préjugés
tous autant que nous sommes nous voulons
un chef ou des chefs et je tiens en ce
moment une brochure dont l'auteur et les
communistes rêve comme un autre mara de
la dictature et donc ça c'est super
intéressant parce que en fait tu te
rends compte qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui sont encore dans cette situation où
la liberté les jupes attire les
oppriment parce que c'est pas ça c'est
la liberté les
les
les inquiète ils sont perdus quand ils
ont trop de liberté et donc on a besoin
d'avoir un chef et donc c'est assez
dingue que voilà on pense que avoir un
chef c'est un truc tout à fait naturel
mais comme on le disait tout à l'heure
avec phoenix quand et avec tes potes
généralement il n'y a pas de chef mais
voilà comment fonctionne le groupe de
manière totalement anarchique donc c'est
pas du tout naturel d'avoir un chef j'ai
envie de dire c'est tout aussi naturel
est pas naturel d'avoir un chef que
d'être dans un mode de fonctionnement
anarchique mais proudhon nous dit voilà
on est dans une représentation du monde
dans laquelle on trouve qu'il faut qu'il
y ait un chef voilà pour le terme
anarchique alors on va aller au début du
document parce que c'est très
intéressant ce que dit coudon
sur le début du texte alors là on vient
vraiment sur le truc que vous entendrez
quand vous vous intéresserez à proudhon
c'est la propriété c'est du vol donc on
va vraiment c'est vraiment ici dans le
début du texte qu'on en parle si j'avais
à répondre à la question suivante
qu'est-ce que l' esclavage et que d'un
seul mot je répondis c'est l'assassinât
maman ma pensée serait d'abord comprise
je n'aurai pas besoin d'un long discours
pour montrer que le pouvoir doter à
l'homme la pensée la volonté la
personnalité est un pouvoir de vie et de
mort et que faire un homme esclave c'est
l'assassiner pourquoi donc à cette autre
demande qu'est ce que la propriété ne
puis-je pas répondre de même c'est le
vol sans avoir la certitude de ne pas
être entendus bien que cette seconde
proposition ne soit que la première
transformé donc ça c'est déjà
intéressant
comme comme proposition alors il faut
savoir je l'avais dit tout à l'heure où
dont ne s'oppose pas à toutes formes de
propriété quoi mais c'est vraiment à la
forme de propriété capitaliste qu'ils
s'opposent d'abord prioritairement c'est
ce que j'expliquais tout à l'heure tu te
promènes a envie d'aller sur site dans
une forêt dont sur un champ à tout ça tu
peux pas parce que c'est un terrain
privé tu te dis même à quoi bon quoi
c'est du vol parce que ça m'appartient
autant ou alors quand tu penses aux
ressources qui sont dans le sous-sol
pourquoi est-ce 15 maman ça appartient à
une société minière pourquoi est ce que
ce rapport un moment ça appartient à une
entreprise moi je suis moi même très
choqué dans en bois le nid à un superbe
site karstique des grottes qui s'appelle
les grottes de han en fait moi j'adore
tout ce qui est géologie et tu peux pas
aller en fait dans ces grottes parce que
ça appartient c'était des grottes de han
alors que c'est quelque chose de naturel
qui a été proposé voilà par la nature et
tu peux pas y aller donc danser dans ces
situations là moi je trouve que la
propriété c'est clairement du vol
puisque toi tu es volet de de ce à quoi
la collectivité volet de cette ressource
là qui était en fête pour tout le monde
c'est comme voilà un jour l'air sera
peut être privatisée un jour peut être
l'eau est déjà privatisés ce qui est
complètement dingue tu es l'auteur
enseigne que la propriété est un droit
civil parce que souvent on dit voilà la
propriété c'est un petit peu les droits
fondamentaux c'est un droit naturel le
droit à la propriété d'ailleurs on va
voir après que proudhon reprend la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et
valait vraiment la critique est vraiment
un travail de constitutionnalistes et on
sent source dans le travail
et ces doctrines tout oppose et qu'elle
semble sont encouragés applaudi parce
que on va dire oui la propriété c'est
soit un droit c'est ce qu'on a vu dans
la vidéo de l'école du chat noir mais ça
peut être aussi parce que les gens au
travail est finalement ils ont acquis
quelque chose par leur travail ça peut
être une autre justification de la
propriété et proudhon alors voir
peut-être pas tout voir ici parce que le
but c'est pas tout lire et à 177 pages
voit pas tout lire c'est ça vous
intéresse vous irez voir vous même ou
dont va déconstruire les deux en fait il
va montrer que la propriétaire n'a aucun
sens qu'elles soient pris sous l'angle
du droit naturel ou qu'elles soient pris
sous l'angle du travail ah oui le dc1 la
propriété c'est du vol quel renversement
des idées humaine
en effet je trouve que c'est assez
renversant voilà un peu plus loin pour
retrouver le passage justement il va
critiquer la propriété d'un point de vue
du droit naturel
parce que ce qu'on a vu dans les stream
précédent on a beaucoup parlé aussi de
la démocratie libérale on a vu que dans
les démocraties libérales le premier
principe c'est finalement de garantir
les droits naturels comme les droits de
l'homme par notre naissance nous les
êtres humains nous avons des droits qui
sont fondamentaux qui sont inaliénables
qui sont vrille est vraiment lié à notre
personne bon c'est quand même une
certaine avancée quand même dans
l'histoire de l'humanité mais ici coudes
on va montrer que la propriété ça n'en
fait pas partie le droit romain défini à
propriété comme le droit d'user ou
d'abuser de la chose on a essayé de
justifier le mot abusé en disant qu'il
exprime non la bu un sens c'est immoral
mais seulement le domaine absolue parce
que ce terme abusé d'un point de vue
économique c'est complètement dingue
c'est moi ça me directement savez-vous
que chez moi vous savez comme ces ses
rennes où ces princesses ou que sais-je
qui faisait des bains ou dans du lait ou
dans des trucs précieux et on voit ça
encore maintenant avec des gens qui font
des bains dans du vin de la bière que
sais-je quoi pour moi c'est vraiment
gaspiller des richesses bien c'est ça
voilà tu achète quelque chose et parce
que tu sais de 7 ha propriété tu en fais
ce que tu veux tu peux acheter si tu as
le pognon pour tu peux t'acheter ce que
tu veux comme comme bouteilles de grands
crus d'ingrandes un grand bordeaux et tu
peux faire strictement ce que tu en veux
si tu as envie de d'arroser les plantes
avec un grand cru tu as le droit de le
faire parce que c'est ta propriété donc
ce terme abusé finalement il est un peu
une fois qu'on comprend les choses
telles qu'elles sont en essayant
vraiment d'avoir aucun a priori c'est un
peu choquant quoi abusé de sa propriété
quelque part et c'est ce que dit
proudhon parce qu'on dit on peut
toujours justifiées avoir le rôle du
canard comme dans l'école du chat noir
vous allez voir l'école du chat noir
pour ceux qui qui nous ont rejoints un
peu plus tard vous allez voir c'est
vraiment une pépite sur l'anarchisme je
vous remets très le lien est donc ici à
proudhon va déconstruire sahin comme si
on avait le canard qui venaient à dire
oui mais c'est pas tellement abusé
distinction 20 devait nous dit bourdon
imaginé pour la sanctification de la
propriété et 100 efficace contre les
délires de la jouissance qu'elle ne
prévient ni ne réprime le propriétaire
est m de laisser pourrir ses fruits sur
pied de ce met du sel dans son champ de
traire ses vaches sur le sable de
changer une vignon désert
et de faire un parc du haut d'un potager
tout cela est il oui ou non de la bu en
matière de propriété lusage et l'abus
nécessairement se confondent et ça c'est
déjà quelque chose qui est très puissant
et je trouve très moderne parce que
parfois je suis scandalisé mais je
suppose que vous l'être aussi vous vous
l'êtes aussi quand on a vraiment des
délires de deux milliardaires qui font
des trucs mais totalement
incroyablement inutile quoi evin qui
vont gaspiller des ressources mais quand
tu vois des villas qui sont qui sont
avec je sais pas combien de salles de
bains qui sont en plein parfois en plein
désert quand tu penses à las vegas où
les pelouses sont arrosés
alors que on est dans un endroit où on
est sans stress hydrique mais tu te dis
mais on est dans quel délire tout ça
parce que les gens ont la capacité de se
rendre propriétaire de certaines choses
quoi des prout ont beaucoup dont l'avait
déjà mis sur la table en 1840 le droit
de jouir de disposer à son gré de ses
biens de ses revenus du fruit de son
travail et de son industrie ça c'est ce
que nous dit la déclaration des droits
de la constitution de 93 d'accord le
code napoléon évidemment lui se base sur
les textes de son époque mais pour aller
voir si actuellement on parle toujours
de la propriété dans les textes
constitutionnels la propriété le droit
de jouir disposer des choses de la
manière la plus absolue donc voilà on en
fait ce qu'on en veut pourvu qu'on en
fasse pas un usage prohibé par les lois
ou des règlements nous précise le code
napoléon
ces deux définitions reviennent à celle
du droit romain toutes reconnaissent aux
propriétaires un droit oups absolu sur
la chose mais coudon ici va distinguer
déjà ce qu est la propriété de ce qu'est
la possession en fait et s'il s'oppose à
la propriété un qui renvoie vers une
réalité capitaliste on l'a bien compris
il est beaucoup moins opposées même
plutôt en faveur d'une possession
et après je ferai un petit lien avec de
la pop culture
c'est un truc qui m'a directement
marquer quand j'avais vu ça à l'époque
la propriété pure et simple
c'est la nue propriété c quant à la la
chose tu es propriétaire du truc docta
un appartement que tulle ou à quelqu'un
toi tu es tu à la nue propriété
tu as l'approprient tué le propriétaire
pure et simple tandis que la possession
sait-on locataires par exemple la
propriété est un droit une faculté
légale la possession est un fait tu vois
le locataire le fermier le commandité
l'usufruitier sont les possesseurs
lemaitre qui loue qui prêtent à usage
l'héritier qui n'attend pour jouir que
le décès dans les unités sont les
propriétaires si j'ose me servir de
cette comparaison un amant est un
possesseur un mari est un propriétaire
doit toujours côté un peu misogyne de
de proue du moins ce qui est élu et ce
qui lui a été reprochée
nombreuses reprises par exemple ici nous
dit boudon donc on dit que il ya la
propriété et que ça serait un droit
naturel comme la légalité comme l'est la
sûreté comme l'est la liberté cependant
si l'on compare entre eux ces 3 ou c4
droit on trouve que la propriété ne
ressemble point du tout aux autres parce
que la liberté elle est inviolable
je ne puis ni vendre ni aliéné ma
liberté tout contrat toutes conditions
contractuelles qui aurait l'aliénation
la suspension de la liberté pour objet
nuls l'esclave qui met le pied sur un
sol de liberté à l'instant même est
libre toi tu es libre où t'es pas libres
dans les droits ont la propriété on voit
que c'est pas du tout au même niveau
lorsque la société saisi un malfaiteur
et le prive de sa liberté elle est dans
le cas de légitime défense quiconque
rompt le pacte social par un crime se
déclare admis public en attaquant la
liberté des autres il les force de lui
ôter la ciel la liberté la condition
première de l'état de l'homme
renoncer à liberté serait renoncer à la
qualité d'homme comment pourrait-on
après cela faire acte d'hommes donc
voilà dans la déclaration des droits de
l'homme on comprend bien toute la
puissance de deux sets ce droit qu'est
la liberté pareillement l'égalité devant
la loi ne souffre ni restriction ni
exception s'il ya égalité devant la loi
tu peux passer des tas liberté tu peux
pas avoir eu moins de liberté moins
d'égalité par donc un autre si si si
tout le monde est égal tout le monde est
égal devant la loi quoi 6e devant la loi
c'est pas une égalité de conditions il
en est de même pour le droit de la
sûreté quoi tu vois cd absolue quelque
part et on voit bien que la propriété
nous dit où proudhon c'est pas du tout
un absolu comme comme l'est la liberté
la sûreté ou l'égalité
donc bien la preuve que c'est une fausse
info droits naturels
la liberté la sûreté du riche ne souffre
pas de la liberté de la sûreté du pauvre
loin de là elles peuvent se fortifier se
soutenir multi mutuellement au contraire
le droit de propriété du premier a
besoin d'être sans cesse défendu contre
l'instinct de propriété du second
quelle contradiction donc on voit que
sur la propriété est un jeu à somme
nulle à ce que l'un à l'autre n'a pas et
c'est parce qu'on trouve sur l'égalité
la sûreté ou la liberté donc je trouve
que la la la l'argumentation de proudhon
est assez convaincante c'est intéressant
de réfléchir à ses conceptions de la
propriété
pour moi il peut y avoir différents
types de propriétés si on fait vraiment
de la fiction comme ça bon ici ou d'onde
il ya celui qui utilise est celui qui
possède avec le capital ou non ses étés
où c'est la propriété qui est la
propriété capitaliste mais pou donc
voila nous propose la possession qui est
serait une autre forme de propriété il
ya aussi dans le seigneur des anneaux
alors je suis très peu fans de tolkien
mais je me souviens de sa dent dans le
seigneur des anneaux les elfes je crois
que c'est les elfes quand ils ont fait
quelque chose ça leur appartient là
c'est la propriété appartient à celui
qui a fait quoi c'est une autre forme de
propriété et ça ça va inspirer
profondément marc st je pense alors je
sais pas si marx avait déjà l'idée en
tête mais en tout cas ça soit à inspirer
marque puisque s'écrire dans le capital
soit ça a fait écho à marx le
capitaliste dit on a payé les journées
des ouvriers pour être exact
il faut dire que le capitaliste à payer
autant de fois une journée qui l'a
employé d'ouvriers chaque jour ce qui
n'est point du tout la même chose car
cette force immense qui résultent de
l'union et de l'harmonie des
travailleurs de la convergence et de la
simultanéité de leurs efforts il ne l'a
point payer 2 donc ils à payer
individuellement les ouvriers mais pas
payer ce que ça fait le travail
collectif le travail social finalement
200 grenadiers ont en quelque sorte en
groupe ou en quelques heures dressait
l'obélisque de luxe or sur sa base
suppose-t-on qu'un seul homme en 200
jours en serait venu à bout cependant au
compte du capitaliste la somme des
salaires hu était la même et bien un
désert à mettre en culture une maison à
bâtir une manufacture exploiter ces
l'obélisque a soulevé c'est une montagne
à changer de place la plus petite
fortune le plus mince établissements la
mise en train de la plus chétives
industrie
exige un concours de travaux et de
talent si divers que le même homme n'y
suffiraient jamais il est étonnant que
les économistes ne l'est pas remarqué
faisons donc la balance de ce que le
capitaliste a reçu et de ce qu'il a payé
donc là on retrouve c'est vraiment échos
la théorie de la plus-value capitaliste
va finalement prendre possession d'une
partie du travail qu'il n'a pas qu'il
n'a pas payé c'est comme ça que
s'enrichit le capitaliste parce que pour
marx il n'ya de valeur que dans le temps
de travail humain finalement personne
n'est en mesure de dire d'où vient la
propriété parce qu'en fait elle vient de
nulle part la propriété c'est juste une
convention c'est celui qui a mis son
drapeau instrument un endroit qui a dit
ça c'est à moi donc la propriété c'est
du vol oui c'est une violence au départ
puisqu'il faut quand même
prendre possession de quelque chose
initialement quoi et de dire ça c'est à
moi et finalement après par l'héritage
de le passer à ses successeurs le
théâtre d'ici seront est commun à tous
est cependant la place que chacun occupe
edit sienne c'est évidemment qu'elles
aient une place posséder non une place
appropriée
cette comparaison anéanti la propriété
de plus elle implique égalité puis-je
dans un théâtre occupé simultanément une
place au parterre une autre dans les
loges une troisième vers les combles non
à moins d'avoir trois corps comme dit
non j'ai pas si on digère ion ou
d'exister au même moment en des lieux
différents donc ça c'est une idée aussi
que les enfants peuvent avoir en juillet
mais à quoi ça sert d'être riche à
partir du moment où c'est pas profiter
de sa richesse et c'est cela qui est
très vieille finalement puisque bon ça
remonte à cicéron ou à quoi ça sert
d'avoir plus que ce que tu ne peux
utiliser ce que d'une buse est ce qu'on
retrouve aussi chez marsh marx nul n'a
droit qu'à ce qui lui suffit d'après
cicéron telle interprétation fidèle de
son fameux axiome nul n'a droit qu'à ce
qui lui suffit et donc on pourrait dire
oui tu vas prendre propriété de ce que
tu as besoin pour vivre donc tu va
cultiver son lopin de terre et des
choses comme ça mais il ya plus que ça
parce qu'il ya une prise de possession
de même des territoires alors on peut
avoir aussi la vision de la conquête de
l'ouest où les colons ont finalement
vaut prendre possession de territoires
qui est utilisé par d'autres simplement
en créant le droit et par
l'intermédiaire de l'état moderne qui va
garantir ces droits vont pouvoir
s'enrichir finalement quoi donc il ya
toute cette idée qu'on retrouve chez
marx aussi dans un chapitre qui
s'appelle
l'accumulation pardon primitif
l'accumulation primitive cinq chapitres
du du premier livre du capital
donc assurément il faut que ça se passe
évidemment
ce moment ce moment initial alors
intéressant de remonter de savoir
exactement quand ça s'est passé dans nos
sociétés c'est ce que rappelle ici à
proudhon alors site des auteurs dans
l'origine toutes choses étaient communes
et à divise elle était le patrimoine de
tous n'allons pas plus loin grotius nous
racontait comment cette communauté
primitive finit par l'ambition et la
cupidité comment à l'âge d'or succède à
l'âge de fer et ainsi de suite en sorte
que la propriété aurait sa source
d'abord dans la guerre et la conquête
puis dans des traités des contrats c'est
ce que j'expliquais mais ouf
est traité et ces contrats ont fait les
parts égales conformément la communauté
originel seule règle de distribution que
les premiers hommes puissent connaître
seule forme de justice qu'ils puissent
concevoir et alors la question d'origine
se présente comment un peu plus tard
l'égalité at-elle disparu ou bien c'est
traiter ces contrats furent imposés par
la force est reçu par la faiblesse et
dans ce cas ils sont nuls le
consentement tacite de la postérité ne
les valide points et nous vivons dans un
état permanent dignité et de fraude
c'est radical non seulement l'occupation
conduit à l'égalité elle empêche la
propriété dont convient sur la
possession à la distinction entre
propriété qui est la propriété
capitaliste
posséder quelque chose en fer ce qu'on
en veut et la possession c'est en avoir
l'usufruit en avoir l'utilisation l'
usage non seulement l'occupation conduit
à l'égalité elle empêche la propriété et
donc proudhon lui va bien sûr se poser à
la propriété capitaliste mais va être en
faveur plutôt d'une défense de l' usage
et on retrouve aussi l'idée marxiste à
chacun selon ses besoins à chacun selon
ses moyens donc quand chacun selon ses
besoins certainement ici mais encore une
fois j'ai déjà dit il ya de filiation
entre entreprises ont qui précède marx
il se il se sont côtoyés
correspondance et tous qu'après ce sont
un petit peu il ya eu un peu dispute
après
mais au début en 1840 et se côtoient
ou à un peu plus tard peut-être en 46 je
pense ça c'est sûr il s'ensuit donc j'en
étais à la reprise que tout homme a
droit d'occuper par cela seul qu'il
existe et qu'il ne peut se passer pour
vivre une matière d'exploitation et de
travailler puisque d'autre part le
nombre des occupants varient
continuellement par la naissance et de
décès il s'ensuit que la quantité de
matière à laquelle chaque travailleur
peu près tenté variables comme le nombre
des occupants par conséquent que
l'occupation est toujours subordonné à
la population enfin que la possession en
droit ne pouvant jamais demeuré fixe il
est impossible en fait qu'elle devienne
propriété quoi
voilà bam là ça pète mais après voilà
mes gens tendent les réclamations des
partisans d'un autre système le travail
le travail qui fait la propriété lecteur
ne vous y trompez pas ce nouveau
fondement de la propriété est pire que
le premier et j'aurai tout à l'heure à
vous demander pardon d'avoir démontré
des choses plus claires d'avoir réfuter
des prétentions plus injuste que toutes
celles que vous avez vu voilà ici
chapitre iii là c'est sa critique du du
travail comme source de propriété parce
que ce qu'il veut vraiment montrer c'est
que le la propriété c'est un artefact
c'est quelque chose qui n'a aucune
aucune naturalité qui est vraiment une
convention sociale et donc qu'il faut
sans doute déconstruire oui après is
here critique la propriété pour dire que
finalement le capitaliste on tire un
profit mais sur base de rien puisque lui
est totalement oisifs et de sa propriété
il va louer en ce qu on dit si les
fermages pour les ter les loyers pour
les maisons les meubles et rentrent pour
les fonds placés à perpétuité intérêts
bénéfices qui en profite pour les
échanges et donc le capitaliste lui il
va utiliser ça pour créer de la richesse
mais sur base de rien
en étant totalement oisifs
et donc là il repart aussi dans des
objections qu'il traite les unes après
les autres bon l'huile et à fond sur la
propriété surtout la part à la propriété
foncière le les terres
d'un doute qu'à son époque c'est surtout
ça qui est très discutée il constitue la
modernité de ce moment là dit voilà si
on considère la terre comme un outil on
n'est pas vraiment face à un outil est
là c'est ce qui va comparer le forgeron
qui fabrique pour le labour des
instruments aratoires le charron qui lui
a fait une voiture lemaçon qui bâtit sa
grange le charpentier lebannier etc qui
tous contribuer à la production agricole
par les outils qu'il prépare son
producteur d'utilité à ce triste ils ont
droit à une part des produits le
forgeron qui a fait la charrue lui il a
bien droit d'avoir une partie du revenu
du laboureur mais la terre est aussi un
instrument dont le service doit être
payé 10 et donc lui va s'opposer à cette
vision là que la terre est un instrument
je tombe d'accord que la terre est un
instrument mais quel en est l'ouvrier
est ce le propriétaire est ce lui qui
par la vertu efficace du droit de
propriété par cette qualité morale
infuse dans le sol lui communique la
vigueur et la fécondité a ses limites la
limite foutage de gueule même c'est à
dire de tilly voilà précisément en quoi
consiste le monopole du propriétaire que
n'ayant pas fait l'instrument ils sont
fait payer le service que le créateur se
présente alors on sait que dans la
bouche de de proudhon ben voilà le
créateur ils y croient pas trop se
présenter vienne lui-même réclamé le
fermage de la terre nous contre 11 avec
lui ou bien que le propriétaire soit
disant fondé de pouvoir montre sa
préoccupation est donc là il va faire
des liens aussi avec l'air avec l'eau
bon avec l'eau du coup aujourd'hui ça a
un peu changé puisque l'eau est
privatisée aussi a très peu de sources
ou de fontaines tu peux utiliser même
quand tu utilises pluie en belgique tu
as une taxe qui existe parce que tu as
une citerne d'eau de pluie par exemple
parce que tu va utiliser
les canalisations après pour évacuer
cette pluie quand tu l'a utilisé donc
aujourd'hui même l'exemple que va
prendre proudhon pour nous montrer que à
être propriétaire d'une terre ça n'a pas
de sens il va dire ben regarde et être
propriétaire de l'osce a pas de sens
aujourd'hui l'eau est devenue une
propriété donc c'est ici le noeud
l'énigme l'arcane de la propriété qu'il
est essentiel de bien des mails et si
l'on veut comprendre quelque chose
étrange effet du droit d'aubaine donc le
droit de ben c'est le fait que tu vas
loup est à terre que tu va percevoir un
loyer par rapport à ta propriété
tu va obtenir une rente par rapport à
cette propriété quel que soit le type de
propriété l'ouvrier qui frappe qui
fabriquent ou qui répare les instruments
du cultivateur on reçoit le prix une
fois soit au moment de la livraison soit
en plusieurs paiements et ce prix une
fois payées à l'ouvrier les outils qu'il
a livrée ne lui appartiennent plus
contrairement aux elfes de talk et main
comme on le disait tout à l'heure jamais
ils ne réclament double salaire pour un
même outil une même réparation si tous
les ans il partage avec le fermier c'est
que tous les ans il fait quelque chose
pour le fermier le propriétaire au
rebours ne sait rien de son instrument
éternellement ils sont fait payer
éternellement il le conserve en effet le
loyer que perçoit le propriétaire n'a
pas pour objet les frais d'entretien et
de réparation de l'instrument ces frais
demeure à la charge de lui qui loue et
ne regarde le propriétaire que comme
intéressé à la conservation de la chose
s'il se charge d'y pourvoir il a soin de
se faire rembourser de ses avances alors
pour un pour un appartement par exemple
une habitation
on pourrait se dire que l'exemple de
proudhon n'est plus trop actuelle mais
si on prend l'exemple d'une terre cité
est propriétaire d'une terre c'est pas
celui qui est propriétaire qui va venir
mettre des engrais ou venir m comme on
appelle ça des amendements pour
améliorer cette terre c'est bien celui
qui la cultivent celui qui en a la
possession pour reprendre les termes de
coûts dont pardon
donc voilà ça c'est assez intéressant et
c'est vrai que c'est un argument qui est
qui et radicale encore une fois le
radical c'est vraiment aller à la racine
des choses et la prude ont vraiment
déconstruit toute cette propriété
capitaliste donc entre le propriétaire
le fermier il n'ya point des changes de
valeur ni de service donc ainsi que nous
l'avons dit dans l'axiome le fermage est
une véritable aubaine le fait que ce
soit vraiment une rente une extorsion et
extorsion fondée uniquement sur la
fraude et la violence d'une part sur la
faiblesse faiblesse et l'ignorance de
l'autre les produits disent les
économistes ne s'achète que par des
produits cet aphorisme et la
condamnation de la propriété le
propriétaire ne produisant ni par lui
même ni par son instrument et recevant
des produits en échange de rien et où un
parasite ou un larron donc si la
propriété ne peut exister que comme
droit la propriété est impossible vous
pondent and the line oui donc à tout cet
aspect là de la propriété intellectuelle
qui évidemment prat pas traitée par
proudhon parce que c'est pas l'enjeu de
l'époque mais en effet quoi cette
question de la propriété intellectuelle
c'est aussi à ces questionnements il
faut regarder les penseurs anarchiste
contemporain
comment il traite cette question là et
puis aussi un autre développement plus
contemporain qu'on pourrait faire par
rapport à tout ce que nous raconte ici
proudhon c'est les changements de
propriété aussi et de possession quand
tu penses au vélib aux voitures
partagées mais aussi netflix des
plateformes ou finalement occuper un
service et faut pas aller très loin même
dans cet ordinateur il ya une licence
office 365 est finalement voilà tu n'a
même plus la propriété du truc quoi donc
il ya une dépossession
aussi à ce moment là non pas une
dépossession une des
propriétés isation jeu comment on
pourrait dire ça de certaines propriétés
puisque tu ne veux même plus la
propriété tu n'en as plus que la
possession au sens de de proudhon donc
ça serait aussi intéressant de
réactualiser sa et de voir un petit peu
les commentaires plus actuel de de
proudhon voilà moi je propose d'en
rester là allez salut salut et à bientôt
ciao